earlier in the show I told you about the
utter and total disaster that is the
proposal from Republicans to replace the
Affordable Care Act called the American
Health Care Act or what should
ultimately be dubbed if signed into law
by President Trump Trump Care I want to
focus in on sort of a micro story
related to that Republican Utah
congressman jason Chaffetz defended the
Republican House members plan for the
American Health Care Act by saying on
CNN hey listen poor people should just
spend money on health care instead of on
new iPhones I know you're probably
wondering what on earth he's talking
about here he is from CNN Americans have
choices and they've got to make a choice
and so maybe rather than getting that
new iPhone that they just love and they
want to go spend hundreds of dollars
that maybe they should invest it in
their own health care they've got to
make those decisions themselves this is
total bottom-feeding hypocrisy first of
all jason Chaffetz gets taxpayer
subsidized health care okay that's
number one his health care isn't at risk
of changing or going away or costing him
more out of pocket he's all set so for
him to tell other people don't go buy
iPhones and instead spend more money on
health care if your health care costs go
up it's hypocritical at its face but the
iPhone thing has completely blown up in
his face because investigative reporter
and many time david pakman show guest
lee fong uncovered this which i'm
putting up on the screen for you this is
a statement from the Chaifetz campaigns
FEC filings which show that his donors
are paying not only for his Verizon
mobile phone bills which ranged from
four to five hundred dollars per month
last year but also his Apple electronics
this is a disclosure form which points
to a disbursement on July 15th of 2016
to a little old business called the
Apple Store for seven hundred and thirty
eight dollars and eight cents on that
day Chaffetz or someone from his office
spent that seven hundred and thirty
eight dollars plus an additional $36
probably for a case to go with his new
iPhone at an Apple store in Salt Lake
City
using funds from the Friends of jason
chaffetz committee the New York Daily
News reports that since 2014 the Friends
of jason Chaffetz committee has actually
filed more than 20 expenditures for
Verizon Wireless for a total of I hope
you're sitting Pat yeah your city well
you sit the entire show so we're fine
eleven thousand twenty one dollars
eleven thousand twenty one dollars
including iPads iPhones etc etc so it's
not just about whether other people are
choosing to spend their money on iPhones
or healthcare jason Chaffetz is spending
other people's money on both iPhones for
himself and taxpayer money is going
towards his congressionally provided
health care to be super clear it's not
rare nor is it illegal that any of this
is going on it exposes the idiocy of the
comparison that jason Chaffetz made on
CNN he doesn't pay for his own health
care
he doesn't pay for his own iPhones and
he responds to a bill that could explode
the cost of health care for his
constituents mostly not people that make
a hundred and seventy five thousand a
year or whatever the Congressional
salary is at this point people not
making a hundred and seventy five
thousand dollars a year but making far
less than that it could explode their
health care costs and he responds by
saying hey pick healthcare instead of an
iPhone he also by the way doesn't
understand that in the US because we
have this thing called for-profit health
care you can have a smartphone and a
well-paying job and you still might end
up having to mortgage your house to pay
for health care or go bankrupt
completely which is fundamentally and
systemically something that shouldn't
ever happen and it actually doesn't
happen in most other countries at our
level of development this is completely
depraved and it seems like when he went
on CNN that he was trying to talk down
to poor people oh yeah as if they're
looking for handouts or somehow don't
have their priorities straight right
it's great when he gets called out on
the same thing that he's alleging that
he's a recipient of things like
corporate welfare and that the people at
the top people in power people at the
top 1% are playing by a different set of
rules than people at the bottom and it's
actually even more depraved than that
because the Republican Party the party
of jason Chaffetz the
can party on under president donald
plans to make healthcare more expensive
as as we expose today by by telling you
about the American healthcare act but
also their net neutrality opposition is
going to make Internet access and mobile
phone plans and maybe even mobile phones
themselves also more expensive and by
the way I don't know how many people
have looked at health care costs
recently but $700 every two years for an
iPhone at the full unsubsidized rate
that many people pay that wouldn't even
come close to covering the cost of
health insurance
he wouldn't know that though Pat because
he's not paying for his iPhone and he's
not paying for health insurance so what
does he know about how much they cost
yeah I think the cost for a family plan
per year is roughly equal to about 33
iPhones right would do you know offhand
how much that what that number is on
average that's that's calculated I mean
we know it's a lot I don't have a
hundred dollars for the iPhone I think
like twenty thousand dollars for the
family plan yeah hi there you go
insane so completely vile depraved don't
expect to hear any kind of a walk back I
think he said something like my choice
of words may not have been the best but
the point I made stands or something
like that many people discussing this
with us on our reddit discussion forum
check it out at david pakman.com slash
read it today's episode of the david
pakman show is made possible in part by
Warby Parker eyeglasses Warby Parker
recently did the right thing and ditched
advertising on right-wing conspiracy
website Breitbart pulling their ads off
and you can get the free five-day home
Tryon from Warby Parker check out their
glasses I use them when I'm not wearing
contact lenses I started with the free
at-home trial they send you five pairs
of glasses you see which ones you like
you send them back and whichever one you
pick they will put your prescription in
- I like this because I can actually
show the glasses to other people and not
have to just decide on the spot like in
an eyeglass store the eyeglass industry
is controlled by very few corporations
that keep the prices very very high even
over $300 for prescription glasses with
Warby Parker they start at just 95 bucks
mine costs that including lenses and for
every pair of sole
they give a pair to someone in need so
to try the five pairs and support the
david pakman show go to Warby Parker
trial comm /t DPS